policies like affirmative action have
hampered black upward Mobility
uh and we you know we've had affirmative
action policies in place for a half
century now so we don't have to
speculate about uh what will happen
there's some natural experiments out
there that have already occurred
the University of California system back
in the mid-1990s ended race-based
admissions throughout the entire
University of California system
after it did that black graduation rates
went up
and not by a little bit by more than 50
percent including in the harder
disciplines the more challenging
disciplines of math and science and
engineering
grade point averages uh of of 3.5 or
higher among blacks increased by more
than 50 percent after the University of
California system ended racial
preferences in college admissions so a
policy that had been put in place to
increase the ranks of the black middle
class to increase the number of black
doctors and lawyers and Engineers had in
practice
led to fewer
of these individuals than we would have
had in the absence of the policy so
aside from whether you think affirmative
action is constitutional
um or make sense in an increasingly
pluralistic society to have a racial
spoil system like that in place uh the
other question is whether it actually
works
and I would argue that 50 years of it
shows that it is not working as intended
uh coming from you uh Nick Hill on
anything that Jason has said you know
the question oh well there's no question
that affirmative action has worked to
expand the ranks of the black
professional managerial class over the
last like 40 50 years there's no
question
um and and that's been shown by
countless studies
the University of California example I
don't know for sure that what was just
said is exactly right one thing that
definitely happened after affirmative
action was outlawed in the University of
California system was that the flagship
campuses saw a tremendous drop in
African-American Latino uh enrollments
and
black and Latino enrollments went up at
the at the satellite campuses so there
was less access to some of the Premier
parts of the University California
system when affirmative action went out
but
the the the real issue for me and I
think the really important issue is is
that we spend an inordinate amount of
time thinking about the number of like
black students to get into Harvard or
whatever and we actually don't think
about the whole educational landscape
and how it was transformed since the
1970s public higher education was free
in the University California system
until the 1970s it was free in the city
of New York until the 1970s so now we
know what what's happened since that
time is is that public higher education
has become extremely expensive
the greatest barriers to going to school
for people or the cost
that's the greatest barrier and that's
the one thing that can't seem that we
can't seem to reduce right what do we
get since the 1970s we got cheap
electronics
and we got
costly education
we got cheap consumer goods
and we got
really expensive Health Care
we got a lot of cheap things that kind
of made us have a feeling that we have a
decent standard of living but the cost
of housing skyrocketed
so this is about political economy right
and I really think that these are the
things that we should be talking about
because when we're talking about people
of modest means people who are who have
to work for a wage people that don't
have inherited wealth
people that come into the world with
disadvantages based upon past
discrimination
then these are the things that really
matter
and affirmative action has helped in
some Realms where it was designed to do
so it has helped to diversify the
professions
it is especially helped white women
Yale's faculty in 1976 was 1.6 percent
women it's faculty of Arts and Sciences
can you believe that 1.6 women
and now it's closer to 50 percent that's
a good thing
that was part of what affirmative action
did it didn't just do stuff for African
Americans it's not just a policy that
was even just about African Americans it
was about the gendered and racial
segmentation of the professions and that
changed since the 1970s in a way that's
a really really good thing for our
society whether it should continue now
and what should be the policy now is an
open question and I'm certainly willing
to have that conversation
um I guess Jason what perhaps you can
have an exchange of Jason says make a
comment yeah the professor says as if
it's just uh as true as the fact that
the sky is blue or water is wet that
affirmative action
um
is is working
and and that it is increasing the ranks
of the black middle class
um again there was a black middle class
before affirmative action it has
continued to grow but at a much lower
rate I quoted Robert Putnam directly who
looked at this data and said despite the
fact that white educational gain
attainment was also Rising between 1940
and 1970 black educational attainment
was Rising even faster before 19 between
1940 and 1970 but after 1970 that
catch-up progress drastically slowed in
the case of high school and actually
ended in the case of college this is a
math problem when you're talking about
growing from a really tiny base
[Music]
trust that we're not talking about
simply absolute gains we're talking
about gains Relic black gains relative
to White gains whites weren't standing
still they were advancing as well and
blacks were catching up at a much much
faster rate prior to affirmative action
higher education than they were in the
in the during the affirmative action era
that is the point the issue is to judge
the value of these policies and I think
you can compare them using empirical
data what was going on pre-1970 what's
been going on since and the data shows
that faster progress was taking place in
the pre-affirmative action era I don't I
don't think the data actually shows that
yeah I could also quote Richard Vetter
and they're quoting census data and I've
also just quoted quoted statistics
Harvard's faculty in the 1970s had zero
black faculty among the tenure flat
faculty in the early 1970s it's about
eight percent now so you can look across
the universities in terms of the
diversification of faculties and student
bodies since the 1970s and there were
black people who taught at Ivy League
institutions I'm saying prior to I'm
saying 70. I'm saying among the tenured
faculty in the in arts and science Tom
Seoul taught a Cornell yeah no I'm
talking about I was I mentioned Harvard
just then but I'm not saying that there
was no there were no black faculty at
any uh and any institutions of higher
education of course I'm not saying that
but I'm saying that those numbers have
absolutely increased and only because of
affirmative action not only because of
affirmative without affirmative action
blacks can't teach in the items no no
that's not all what I'm saying that is
not what that is not what I'm saying I'm
saying affirmative action policies have
been part of the diversification of
higher education in a way that has been
helpful and in a way that has actually
worked that's what I'm saying
that's all I'm saying it's really simple
Derek Bach who is president of Harvard
wrote the shape of the river in 1976
they studied
several hundred no no no no I mean it
came out it came in the 1980s but the
study is based upon a group a cohort
that went in under affirmative action
and it should what what they found there
in that in that book was out of the 700
people that they studied
that at the end of that college cohorts
experience over 30 percent had ended up
with Advanced or professional degrees
over 300 of them had become Civic
leaders
and I think around 120 had become
Business Leaders I have it somewhere in
my notes but that's in any way they
found no that is what they think that is
not what they found I can tell you what
they found now that's that is not and
and what they and what they showed in
that study was that those rates were
remarkably similar to and very close to
uh the white cohort that they compared
it to no yeah that book attempted or or
suggested that it was measuring uh
racial preferences in higher education
what Bach and Bowen did not do however
is to disaggregate the blacks who had
been admitted under racial preferences
from the blacks who had not been
admitted under racial preferences but
got into the school Under the same
credentials as everyone else they never
disaggregated that data
they just looped it all together and
reported averages the entire argument
over affirmative action
is not whether
blacks can can do well at these schools
it's whether the blacks who are let in
with lower credentials can do better at
these schools Bowen and Bach did not
disaggregate that data not only did they
not disaggregate it they wouldn't
release
their findings so that other social
scientists could check their findings
and see if they could come up with the
same results that book did not do what
you were suggesting it did well that was
the finding of the book I mean you
you've offered a discrediting of their
finding and that's what social
scientists do they discredit each
other's findings I mean I I didn't come
I didn't come here I didn't come here to
really debate like the merits of
affirmative action I think that we can
we can find like we can find examples of
where affirmative action has succeeded
absolutely and where it has has had
benefits that's really it's really a
minimal claim may I just make just put a
finer Point since we've been discussing
put a final point on the question which
gets back to the question I put to you
Jason are you saying that affirmative
action didn't help or are you saying
that affirmative action hurt and if so
how
it's it's it's done more harm than good
and in a number of ways
um hey I I've just believe it's
unconstitutional well we're talking
about the harm or the good yeah Supreme
consequently beside that um but but
regardless of whether it's it's it's
constitutional I think the data show
that it's done more harm than good and
it's done more harm than good primarily
by setting up smart kids to fail
um I'll give you an example uh there's a
study done of MIT students black
students at MIT some years ago
black students at MIT had scored the
90th percentile on the math portion of
the SAT of all kids in the country
90th percentile
but among their peers at MIT they were
in the 10th percentile
so black students who would be hitting
it out of the park
at a less selective Institution
was struggling at MIT
you mentioned how after California ended
its racial preference policies and
college admissions black enrollment
initially fell at the flagship schools
of UC Berkeley and UCLA
you're right it did those students
however went on
to enroll at UC Santa Cruz
and UC Santa Barbara where they could
handle the work and they graduated
what is the point of flunking out of
Berkeley instead of graduating from UC
Santa Barbara what is the point of
flunking out of MIT or struggling having
to switch to an easier major
rather than graduating in the major you
want to study in from the institution
and that's what I mean when I say that
it is set up smart kids to fail it is
not about these kids not being smart not
being able to handle the work anywhere
not belonging in college it's about
whether they can handle the pace and
it's it has to do and it doesn't it's
not limited to race
um
students who are let in because their
parents went to the school legacies
students who were LED in because of
athletic ability with with lower
credentials than the average student
also struggle at these schools if if you
decided to let in
left-handed blondes with lower
credentials than the average student at
Harvard you would see left-handed
blondes concentrating in the bottom of
their class you would see them
struggling with the work you would see
them dropping out at higher rates that
is what is being done to black people in
the name of helping them no restriction
on they're like well okay we at least we
have the the difference is clear and you
may be able to speak do you want to make
a comment or can we go to a question to
kill yeah I mean I I don't have that
much more to say about it okay I think
we put like way too much emphasis on
affirmative okay all right and that
hasn't really been the the sort of
weight of of the arguments that I've
been making tonight at all about
progressives
because it's a progressive policy it is
one Progressive policy and it's one
Progressive policy that has had some
benefits and it's certainly one perfect
aggressive policy that has engendered a
very large amount of contention and it's
probably about to be ruled
unconstitutional um yeah well okay
fairness
but there's also a way I mean I mean the
military has been one of the biggest
institutions that's been in support of
affirmative action affirmative action
has really been about diversifying
Pathways to leadership that's why people
end up focusing on these these very
elite institutions now has that has that
occurred in in some institutions is is
the military a good example of having
successfully established Pathways to
leadership by using what they would
admit is affirmative action absolutely
so I don't know if you want to
contradict the whole idea of the what
the U.S military has done as an
institution one of the most respected
institutions in American society I mean
go ahead but I would say that there are
probably examples of success so so I'm
not saying that it's the only I'm not
saying it's the only thing that we
should be hinging this argument on you
know I think they're actually really
legitimate agreements I mean legitimate
disagreements to have about affirmative
action and I know why people get so
upset about it it seems it it really is
a contradictory policy we should be a
race-blind society and then we find that
we have to take race into account to
deal with something like this but you
know it's it's it's a very I mean we
should have a separate debate on this
topic because it could go on and on